deux jeunes talents martiniquais
laurence est docteur en entomologie
médical elle est sur diplômés et
pourtant son expertise n'est pas au
service de la martinique
tout simplement parce qu'il n'y avait
pas d'opportunité à la fin de ma thèse
mais c'est pas comme si je ne
travaillais pas je travaille à la
direction des affaires sanitaires
laurence bénéficie dans poste très bien
rémunérées en nouvelle calédonie malgré
tout son objectif c'est de rentrer
travailler en martinique
même pour un salaire moindre pour moi
c'est pas c'est pas le le critère qui
ferait que 6,6 par rapport à mon salaire
que j'ai actuellement nouvelle calédonie
le salaire n'est pas le même c'est pas
ça qui fera que si l'opportunité se
présente de travail à la martinique je
le ferai pas c'est absolument je
rentrerai à la martinique
quel que soit l'opportunité damien a
sauté le pas il ya tout juste six mois
après de longues années de recherches
cet ingénieur en calcul à trouver un
emploi ici je suis confiant on dira
plutôt atypique parce que je ne
travaille pas du tout dans le domaine
avec les étudiants alors
mon employeur a pris le pari de se dire
que j'allais que j'allais pouvoir
m'adapter aux postes qu'ils me
proposaient et que moi ma jeunesse
allait ramener une fraîcheur dans son
entreprise si damien est heureuse d'être
rentrée
il reconnaît qu'il a fallu renoncer à
certains rêves professionnels
on peut perdre prétentions salariales
parce qu'on a peur des fruits les des
employeurs
et puis les fous pour pas se mentir
l'évolution de carrière en matinée est
plus difficile enfin en tout cas de mon
point de vue elle a l'air plus difficile
que si j'étais en france
au delà de leur réussite professionnelle
ces deux jeunes talons disent n'être
motivé que par une chose l'amour de leur
pays
oui il faut partir se former il faut
partir prendre de l'expérience mais
surtout revenir et puis fais permettre à
la martinique d'avoir des talents et
puis que tout ça participe au
développement de la martinique
il faut du militantisme à 100% il faut
du de l'envi il faut deux parce que déjà
trouvé un post ici ça peut être
difficile même si en ayant une thèse en
ayant c'est ça c'est difficile mais il
faut quand même le côté où j'ai envie de
votre chez moi pour le côté vraiment
j'ai martinique j'ai vu que ma
martinique évolué je veux en a marqué
plus jeunes il faut avant ce côté là
parce que sinon on laisse un pays en
perdition de jeunes talents surdiplômés
et pourtant ils n'ont qu'une ambition
celle de porter au sommet l'avenir de la
martinique